this always a double-edged sword
invariably the BS about 80% of what we
do produce here are exported you got to
remember though that normally around
sixty percent of the parts that go into
the cars that are made here come from
abroad so the cost of those parts and
components has gone up so it's not
necessarily a lower pound doesn't
necessarily give you a clear win in
terms of export competitiveness the flip
side of that of course is that about
eighty percent of the cars that we sell
here come from abroad and ultimately the
fall and sterling is going to flow
through an increase in pricing probably
of the magnitude of two or three percent
over the coming months when do you think
motorists will start to feel that I
think you know we will see increasing
prices certainly in the first quarter
what happens after that after the past
Jim is forecast as a really dangerous
game what sort of guarantees do you
think Nissan have received from the UK
government I don't think ministers would
have been in a position to make any such
assurances you know as we continent we
don't know exactly what the nature of
the priority is what the what the plan
is for the negotiations but then
certainly ministers I don't think would
have made any such commitments in such
an uncertain time when you know you're
going into negotiation with 27 other
member states would you like to see the
UK remaining within the customs union we
would as an industry we've been very
clear that the benefits of remaining
within the single market have would have
helped made the industry so successful
that's in terms of having no tariffs
being part of the customs union which
removes any barriers to trade and
obviously its monthly that there's other
benefits as well in terms of access to
that that massive market without any
sort of impediments makes the UK very
competitive when exporting into those
markets clearly it looks like we're
going to leave the single market but
will you be calling for the UK to remain
within the customs union we would like
to see the UK remain within the customs
union because there are clear benefits
remember we are an industry that prides
itself in just-in-time delivery you know
parts and cars will move very quickly
through throughout the system anything
that puts a barrier but causes delay
within that that process adds cost and
cost ultimately is the
is the enemy of competitiveness early
this week Donald Trump made some
comments on Twitter about General Motors
and just hours later Ford announced it
was no longer going ahead with a new
plant in Mexico do you worry about the
Americans become more protectionist I
think in a clearly wats we made to see
what the new administration does and
it's obviously Donald Trump hasn't
formally taken office yet it's still
president-elect you know as an industry
we're very much in favor of free trade
we were very keen to see the development
of T tip for instance because we saw
that as having an absolute benefit for
both UK and American manufacturers in
promoting free trade so anything that
inhibits free trade I think we would see
is potentially dangerous for the
industry but i think it's 20 to draw too
many conclusions from other appointments
or or Twitter remarks